when my husband passed i thought i saw
him everywhere
it was just so hard
does mark ever think he sees her
hey guys pete here today i'll be talking
about severance episode 7. more major
developments unfolded in defiant jazz
and i have to say that i love them all
equally we lost one of my favorite
innies and that's not the biggest thing
that happened that's not even the only
major character death there was and this
is good we can use this mil check
delivers one of his best all-time lines
the music dance experience is officially
cancelled
and i'm not even sure that was the
second best line in the episode there's
audi stuff any stuff severed non-severed
it's a lot to take in and we also had
the release of the lexington letter
companion book in between episodes i'll
be recapping the highlights and what i
think it all means right after this
quick spoiler warning if you haven't
watched severance season 1 episode 7 yet
then this video won't be for you and
with that out of the way let's get into
it
i think that we should just start out
with the ending because i've seen this
i've thought about this and i really
don't know what to make of it in the
closing sequence after getting really
drunk and probably scaring alexa away
for good mark tapes back together the
photo of his wife that he tore up
earlier and while he's doing that he's
saying all the things that he loved
about her which sounded a lot like how
they have their audis described to them
when they do a wellness session that's
also when they're encouraged not to
react to any of the facts because
they're supposed to enjoy them all
equally without preference and of course
at the end he says he loves all those
things about her equally it turns out
when we look at the picture that his
wife looks exactly like miss casey and
that's where things get confusing
because it does seem that his wife died
in a car crash it feels like a pretty
elaborate thing to fake considering his
family believes that we hear devin
talking about it just in this episode
and maybe more than that he seems to be
mourning her not so much in the way that
she decided to leave him and say become
a permanently severed employee either
way there's someone who's labeled as a
part-time severed employee who looks
exactly like his wife and harmony cobell
seems to be trying to figure out if he
remembers her or if they recognize each
other but it's hard to say why so i'm
interested to hear what you guys think
about this please let me know in the
comments i know this got spoiled in the
subreddit a couple of weeks ago so maybe
you've been thinking about it a little
bit longer i went back to look for clues
and beyond miss casey's strange behavior
that seems to be somewhat consistent
with newborn any behavior her being
color coordinated with the candle in
mark's wellness session and pd's claim
that some severed employees never leave
the building harmony questioning if mark
ever sees her in this episode is
probably the biggest one that just kind
of continues to add to the mystery that
surrounds her more than it hints at
what's going on with gemma and i do have
to get into everything else that
happened so i'll come back around to
this at the end the opening sequence
picks up where we left mark at the end
of the last episode we get some
introduction to this character that
greener and cobell refer to as ragabi
she tells mark that she's the person
that implanted his chip and that she's
still the only person that can
deactivate it for what it's worth she's
not the person that implanted heli's she
claims that petey wouldn't have died if
he just followed her post-op
instructions instead of running away she
hints that mark could also be
reintegrated without those same
complications and she does talk to him
about his innie sum saying that he's
only been severed for two years so he's
in he's still a baby and that he brought
him into this world without his
permission based on his own desire for
emotional convenience before they can
get too much into that grainer does show
up and mark doesn't recognize him
because his audi's never met him before
they have a chance to get acquainted
ragabe comes up behind him and hits him
over the head with the baseball bat
until he's dead of course this freaks
mark out and it doesn't help when she
explains that he was the head of
security on the severed floor she pulls
grayner's security card out and gives it
to him explaining that it has full
access and it can't be tied to anyone
she wants him to take it to work
tomorrow saying that his innie will know
what to do with it and i thought it
stood out that she said that i think you
want to do what's right and then added
both of you she did tell mark not to
throw up because of his dna and as soon
as he makes it outside he does that
which may be something that we need to
remember
when he goes back home he strips down to
get rid of all of his clothes like she
told him and alexa is still there while
he was gone she woke up realized that he
left the house and he has to make up a
story about needing to get out and drive
around because he's not comfortable with
what happened between them the next
morning he grabs the key card and puts
the plastic bag with his clothes in with
the rest of his trash right on top which
kind of seems like a bad idea we also
see mrs selvig on her way out and she
makes a comment about how he usually
puts his trash out in the afternoon
milchak has a big day ahead of him at
the office since harmony is moonlighting
over at devin's place and greener well
he's not going to be showing up he
checks the new door that's there to keep
mdr safely situated and he retrieves the
ideographic card that dylan stole from
ond he goes there next to return the
missing 7199g
and tells bert that they can now focus
on the final preparations which i was
thinking was related to their
department's work whatever they're doing
with these cards but it's a little
unclear because he's also putting
together any bert's retirement party
which i suppose you could also call his
pre-death celebration when dylan comes
down he wants to know what happened when
he woke up at his house it's explained
to him that this is called the overtime
contingency which is a safeguard they
occasionally employ to wake up workers
remotely off-site dylan makes it clear
that the innies had no idea that they
could do that and then he asked about
the boy that he saw wondering if it's
his son milcheck tells him that he
shouldn't tell his co-workers about the
otc and when dylan presses him for his
son's name he tells him that not knowing
is probably for the best based on how he
looks it appears that no amount of
special perks can take his mind off of
it you see that he's stewing at his desk
irv is really worried about bert and no
one feels great about being locked
inside their office things take a brief
turn when milcheck starts the musical
dance experience helly gets to choose
the genre and an accessory and the
musical genre names are hilarious she
goes with the maraca and defiant jazz
there are special lights and milcek
starts out dancing with helly and i
don't suppose you could watch this scene
without making a comment about how good
he is at it and generally everyone's
enjoying this and looks happy except for
dylan who stayed at his desk and when
milcek goes up behind him he looks like
he's seething he starts to see images of
his son calling him daddy from the night
before and then he starts to scream he
gets up and tackles milcheck into the
record player and yells tell me his name
over and over as he chokes him he then
bites his shoulder to the point of
breaking the skin until the rest of them
pull him off miltek tries to threaten to
report him but then he realizes dylan
would be happy to go and talk to her
about being woken up at home after he's
gone dylan tells the others that they
can wake them up he tells them the story
he tells them about the overtime
contingency and says that he keeps
reliving the memory and now he has to
have that in his head without ever being
able to see him again irv tries to say
that it's his audi son but it doesn't
fly he's completely pissed off and heli
decides that this is good that they can
use it she thinks they should try to
find out how they do it and then do it
to themselves they'd be able to get a
chance to see the outside world and
learn who their audies really are the
one big problem is they can't get access
and mark shows them that he has
grainer's security card explaining that
he has no idea why his audi would have
it petey had located the office during a
fire drill and showed mark so he knows
where it is they tried the key on the
door and it does work and they leave
dylan there so the rest of them can go
to the office together
as soon as they get into the hall though
irv bales because he has to go find bert
mark and helly are able to get inside
the office and they find that no one's
working inside they get a peek behind
the curtain and there's a lot of
monitoring equipment that looks custom
if not slightly dated to me it looks
more analog than digital but there are
computers involved there's a bunch of
displays with employee names in their
departments and they have numbers next
to their names that change
for the departments there are several
we've never heard of like cl wn w and a
dnr and a few more o and d is noticeably
missing on the main wall and considering
that the only mdr employees are the four
we know that are listed there it's
likely that this list of over 80 names
are all the severed employees from this
location while they're snooping around
they see that harmony is descending in
the non-severed elevator so heli tears
out the instructions for the overtime
contingency protocol and they leave when
they get back to the office they look
those over and they'd think that they
can probably do it but one of them is
gonna have to stay behind dylan
volunteers since he's been out already
and the only hit seems to be that it's
designed to be a two-man operation there
are two switches they have to flip but
dylan assures them he can do it and this
does make you wonder who was there to
help grenor whenever they woke him up
when harmony arrives at her office she
finds natalie there waiting for her with
the board on her headset she explains
that doug greener is dead and that the
board finds this deeply troubling cobell
says whoever killed grener is probably
the same person who reintegrated peter
kilmer but she doesn't go any further
because she says that integration
happened and she has the data to prove
it and she wants to leverage that to get
an in-person meeting with the board
without intermediaries they do agree to
this and tell her that they'll be
available to meet with her at the egan
family gala next week
i mentioned that irv was on his way to
omd to see bert and there's a shot with
him walking down the hall where he pulls
out his mustache comb and things start
to feel like something bad's gonna
happen and it does when he arrives he
learns that they're having a going away
party for bert and that his innie is
essentially dying he's being retired
milcheck wheels in a tv so he can watch
a hilarious message from his audi and he
notices that irv somehow managed to get
out of mdr the video is awkward and he
continuously mentions how he has no idea
about what's happening there while at
the same time saying he will remember
them forever and we do hear him mention
that he's been doing the job for seven
years obviously irv is crushed the whole
world is crushed i think after watching
this and he says out loud you're all
just gonna stand here and let him die he
questions if they're being punished and
milcheck assures him that it's just
about burt's audi retiring that it'll
happen to him too and i don't know it
seems like it's pretty weird timing irv
delivers the best line of the episode
when he says you smug [ __ ]
you're not severed you walk out of here
with your memories there's an argument
but bert convinces miltek to let him
stay they play the song he selected good
morning yesterday by paul anka and
everyone shakes his hand goodbye after
he has his turn milcheck walks her back
to mdr and when he gets back to his
colleagues he tells them let's burn this
place to the ground and since i already
talked about the ending in the beginning
that's pretty much everything that
happened in the episode the one thing i
haven't touched on yet though was the
interaction with devin and mrs selvig
because i just noticed something after i
read the book and i guess i'm a little
bit dim but it hadn't dawned on me that
part of them having funny names like
helly and petey are related to the fact
that their innies are like children in
the book the main character mentions
that her innie was called peggy which
was a name she hadn't been called since
she was a child and so i was thinking
about them talking about how gabby
didn't remember her from the birthing
retreat and her bringing up the idea of
her being severed and it just stood out
that she introduced herself as gabby
which might be an indication that it
wasn't any that she was talking to
another stellar episode from my point of
view last week managed to get me excited
for what was to come while it was one of
the weaker episodes overall sort of a
transition and i think this was an
improvement there were a few things that
felt a little too convenient like the
security card but one of the things i've
always liked about this show is its
ability to keep me engaged to the point
where i'm willing to overlook some
things i think the structure and pace
have felt deliberate and i'm expecting
that things will continue to get more
intense right up until the very end it
felt like we were moving towards
revolution i could have never guessed
that they were going to be able to wake
themselves up outside but that sounds
like a pretty good way to go there's a
popular theory out there that heli is an
eagan she's a member of the family or
something along those lines although we
do know that her last name is riggs for
what that's worth but it all comes from
her insistence on keeping her annie
there her inflexibility to let her go
even after she tried to kill herself
which you know there has to be a reason
for that i'm not sure if it's the case
that she's part of the family i think
there's just as many clues that go
against it as there are for it but this
mention of the upcoming egan family gala
did make me wonder considering they have
this plan to wake themselves up and if
that happens that seems like a pretty
crazy place for that to go down as far
as other theories i've never been too
keen on the one where they are a part of
an experiment or the severed employees
are basically working on themselves
they're editing their code or balancing
their four tempers in kierspeak i think
each week that feels less likely and i
don't know what the work is but after
reading the book i do think it's
somewhat important to lumen like they
are actually being productive i'm not
sure it's as nefarious as peggy k who
was able to get coded messages to her
audi thinks it is and i'm not sure we'll
even understand what it is by the end of
the season but i do think that the work
matters and if you want to go into wild
speculation which is something i don't
generally get into if there's something
to what peggy's saying basically she
thinks that they're doing corporate
espionage those cards that were so
important those could be something that
you could pass off to severed employees
at different companies like your
competitors we do know that lumen isn't
the only company in this world that does
it and they could cause a problem think
about how mdr reacted to reading
ricken's book if you had this childlike
experiential reality that they have and
you had these cards with instructions
that could possibly make it through the
code detectors then you might start
acting funny i still feel like we're
missing a lot and trying to understand
lumen's motivations kier obviously was
interested in his personal legacy his
business and his family legacy that's
intertwined with that we don't know if
he was a snake oil salesman that built a
giant company or if he was a weirdo that
was trying to create a giant cult or if
he was both harmony is part of our
connection to that because she seems to
be really motivated both inside and out
to seeing this dream be realized i got
the sense that she's never been in the
presence of the board and i'm looking
forward to seeing how that plays out
everything that she does related to mark
is just kind of a question and certainly
the reveal that gemma is mrs casey in
some way or another doesn't clear that
up for me the robot theory is looking a
little more likely though i mean like i
said at the beginning i don't know
what's going on there none of the ideas
i come up with sound great it doesn't
mean none of them would work but they
don't inspire confidence i will say that
because burt and erv didn't kiss that
this magical relationship that they
built up in this season ended with a
handshake i suspect that we're gonna see
him again i've never been a fan of the
idea that they know each other in the
outside world but i mean there is the
possibility that they could meet out
there i just feel like it's gonna happen
that any herb will see bert again and to
be clear where we left it that shouldn't
be possible if he retired so at this
point i'm mostly rambling so i will wrap
it up i think this is probably a good
place to leave things i would recommend
reading through the book there's some
interesting stuff in there and it's
short you can get right through it i'll
put links in the video description even
if you don't live in the us or don't
have an apple device you can still read
it so let me know in the comments what
you thought about this episode where you
think things are going what theories are
you latching on to and which musical
genre would you pick in the musical
dance experience please like this video
if you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon